[Música]
yo soy de cádiz
mis padres son de cádiz mi hermana de
cádiz también mis abuelos mis tíos mis
primos todos andaluces bueno mi abuela
tiene un hermano que vive en madrid pero
el tío es de ubrique y hace un año
cuando entré a través de televisión fue
la primera vez que yo estuve en contacto
con catalanes propios o por tu parlan
catalán wines y esto es ni más ni menos
gracias a las canciones
el otro día viendo la última temporada
de big bang theory rats el chico más
tímido del grupo conoce una chica cuyo
más oscuro secreto es que no le gusta la
música señoras y señores ladies and
gentleman no le gusta la música ningún
tipo cero no music claro yo de repente
entró en muerte clínica por unos
segundos ante el aberrante idea de que
si están personas a las que el efecto no
les gusta la música afortunadamente
estas personas son como las meigas
haberlas haylas pero yo no conozco
ninguna
en lo referente a las canciones yo
siempre he sido una excepción sobre todo
en la gente de mi edad cuando salíamos
cuando íbamos a la playa y sacaban ese
pedazo de altavoz reglamentario que
tanto y tanto me hizo sufrir en mi
adolescencia con la idea a mi juicio
incoherente de relajarse mirando la
inmensidad del océano atlántico
escuchando reggaeton puro al que yo
respeto pero no lo cultivo entonces que
hacía yo una vez escuchada un par de
canciones que me servían para entender
los problemas de la mayoría de mis
coetáneos yo sacaba mis auriculares y
entonces me iba decenas de años atrás y
ya así me he relajado en inspirada
pensaba con la guitarra de silvio
rodríguez y su voz por ejemplo donde
nunca me sentí una excepción fue en mi
familia porque mi familia goza de una
gran cultura musical que han sabido
regalarnos tanto a mi hermana como a mí
de hecho la mayoría de grupos de
intérpretes que yo escucho hoy en día
los conocí en los larguísimos viajes en
consigue asia con mi familia un par de
veces al año
yo entendí el mundo gracias a las
canciones titular se podría decir que yo
entendí el mundo gracias a la
investigación de las canciones las
canciones me llevaron a quienes las
escribían y a sus vidas y estos se
convirtieron en mi referente y su
referente también en mi referente y lo
referente de sus referentes también es
muy diferente y así hasta el infinito la
fiesta de la referencia un proceso
bastante inductivo en el que no solo he
aprendido muchísimo y arrojado luz sobre
infinidad de asuntos de los que no tenía
ni idea sino que también he disfrutado
mucho he disfrutado mucho yo que siempre
me jacto de ser libre entre comillas en
estos tiempos que corren con la frase no
me arrepiento de nada de lo que he hecho
sino de lo que no he llegado a hacer por
algún motivo si hay algo de lo que
verdaderamente nunca me arrepentiré es
de haber invertido el tiempo que he
invertido durante tantos años en
aprender en aprender gracias a las
canciones y sus creadores incluso un
idioma entero como ya he dicho ha
aprendido en gran parte gracias a las
canciones yo hablo catalán fluido desde
que tenía 13 años y esto fue porque un
buen día yo descubro una canción
al carrer de joan manuel serrat que
traducido resulta mi calle
esta canción describe a la percepción el
carrete de poeta cabañas del barcelonés
barrio de pobla se que es donde se cría
joan manuel serrat pero también podría
hablar perfectamente del barrio donde se
crió mi padre o mi abuelo la sociedad
real no la más épica que nos cuentan la
gente en la calle la ropa tendida la
pensión el horno de pan gracias a esta
canción yo llego a esa otra mitad de la
discografía de serrat que está escrita
completamente en catalán y luego a otros
grupos e intérpretes catalanes y
posteriormente viene a parar en la
televisión el cine y la poesía de
cataluña sería muy fácil de decir en
términos locales que acércate torito que
ya es la hora de la comparsa la
ventolera de don antonio martínez xerez
me hizo argumentar mi alegato
antitaurino o que de tanto preguntar por
dios a todos los que en él creía del
recientemente fallecido juan carlos
aragón me hizo revisar absolutamente
todos mis valores religiosos fueron
éstos los que fueren pero es así y
desgraciadamente más allá de
despeñaperros aunque cada vez me lo
tengo que decir aún más allá de
despeñaperros no se tiene constancia de
la gran fe
de poesía y musicalidad que se muestra
en cádiz durante todo el año pero bueno
ese es otro tema volviendo a lo que
estaba comentando este proceso que he
seguido de aprendizaje ha sido gracias a
un largo proceso de investigación que
sin interés y sin curiosidad hubiera
sido muy difícil que se hubiera
producido pero bueno no os preocupéis
encontrar la información que buscáis es
muy fácil cualquiera puede hacerlo un
buen método puede ser y más en estos
tiempos en los que la información está
en las teclas de distancia buscar
artistas cuyas vidas estén relacionadas
de alguna manera con ese tema que te
inquieta que te perturba como diría
esperanza gracias por ejemplo la canción
papá cuéntame otra vez de ismael serrano
no basta para comprender los conflictos
armados de la segunda mitad del siglo 20
papá papá papá aunque diga ahora mueren
en bosnia los que morían en bandas pero
si es un ejercicio magnífico a la hora
de entender el papel fundamental de las
revueltas de los jóvenes en épocas de
represión y también entender que la
curiosidad no sólo no mata gatitos sino
que es maravillosa para entender y
conocer la versión de todos los bandos
discernir y sobre todo no repetir la
historia
y la vida de janis dylan y joan baez y
su mensaje pacifista en aquellos años en
los que eeuu era una bomba racista de
relojería las consecuencias de nacer
tras una guerra mundial y coincidiera en
el tiempo con otra que me las encontré
en la vida de edith piaf quien por las
circunstancias de hambre y necesidad que
pasó de niña vio su carrera marcada y su
vida truncada en parte también por esos
grandes excesos de los que los mayores
referentes de la historia no suelen
librarse e incluso entender enfermedades
si las canciones me hicieron entender
enfermedades porque desde que somos
pequeños el cine y la televisión nos
hacen ver que las personas que padecen
trastornos mentales son malas malísimas
y no nos explican que no es su culpa
puede ser dicho trastorno una canción
del ya nombrado serrat que se llama de
cartón-piedra narra perfectamente y de
manera muy poética la historia de amor
entre un chico y un maniquí y es la
historia de amor más grande y más bonita
del mundo cuando yo descubro esta
canción y me entero del significado de
esta canción fue la primera vez que yo
me di cuenta de la importancia que tiene
la empatía y la comprensión para con las
personas con trastornos psiquiátricos
por ejemplo también
una función maravillosa que me cambió la
vida el día que la descubrí una función
de youtube que se llama reproducción
automática porque gracias a ella llegue
a latinoamérica y totalmente gratis pero
figuradamente porque nunca ha estado la
buena noticia es que tengo 21 años y
tengo mucho tiempo para ir por no tener
señoras y señores no tengo ni barba
llegar a latinoamérica llega a
latinoamérica supone un antes y el
después de un después en mi vida no me
marco de muchísima forma porque si algo
tiene por ejemplo el folklore
latinoamericano es que es una
maravillosa hemeroteca musical las
canciones hablan de lo que está pasando
en el momento gracias a la parte del
galgo terrible de víctor jara yo entendí
que no quedan tan atrás las dictaduras y
que el pueblo que se defiende con la
libertad de expresión y la cultura casi
siempre o siempre se va a ver amenazado
por aquellos que no tienen más armas que
la violencia también dueño antiguo de la
flecha es una canción que me lleva
directamente al pueblo de los indios
todas al norte de la argentina un pueblo
que vive en la más absoluta naturaleza
en la más pura esencia de la vida
fabricando pacíficamente sus abalorios
pero que además un estribillo está
escrito en con black tag y es estupendo
para ligar os pongo un ejemplo
pose de ligar tú sabes que yo sé con
black tac y te dice ella como y tú le
dices te voy a cantó una cosa y le canta
indio toba ya viniendo de la calle
quitilipi avia terai [ __ ] azucarada y
guaycurú tapenagá pirané samu matar agua
cada pista alta nadie te entiende y
quedas divinamente
[Aplausos]
del mismo autor del mismo autor ariel
ramírez es la canción alfonsina y el mar
y puedo decir sin temor a equivocarme
que es la canción más importante de mi
vida y esto ya es una curiosidad que yo
me permito contarles y es que yo cuando
vivía málaga vivía en la plaza alfonsina
storni cuando estuve la oportunidad de
cantar en 'prime time' 'alfonsina y el
mar' antes ya lo hacía y ahora lo sigo
haciendo cada vez que puedo incluso en
la línea de metro que yo tomo todos los
días con mi legañas para ir al centro de
madrid hay una pegatina con el poema de
alfonsina storni que inspiró la canción
una curiosidad en la vida lo referente
pueden ser de vital importancia para
muchas cosas puedes buscar e
identificarse con la orientación sexual
de algún artista y como éste la explica
en su obra o también entender por qué tu
amiga ya no pasa tanto tiempo contigo y
prefiere estar con su pareja que es lo
que sientes y se alejan aunque claro las
canciones vuelve a decir que no son la
panacea para conocer el amor te tienes
que enamorar y también te pueden jugar
malas pasadas porque yo he tenido
relaciones sentimentales y a mí nadie me
ha dado
canción como dice silvio rodríguez o sea
estoy me siento animado
en cualquier caso vuelvo a preguntarme
cómo puede haber gente a la que no le
gusta la música y esta pregunta me lleva
directamente a otra que sería de mí sin
la música
probablemente no hablaría a otro idioma
que no fuera el castellano y este lo
hablaría mucho peor no tendría ideales
propios y estaría comulgando con unos
valores una religión y una sociedad que
quizá no me representarían tanto no
tendría ni idea de la sociedad real de
la gente y sus problemas no me habría
preocupado en entender las enfermedades
mentales simplemente miraría para otro
lado hasta que no me tocaran de cerca no
entendería el amor como algo que se
siente y es humano y en el que no cabe
en abuso ni desventaja no habría
conocido a mi gran amor que es
latinoamérica
mi valor haría mi otro gran amor que es
cádiz como se merece y por supuestísimo
y más importante no sabría ligar en con
black tag
en definitiva me quedaría vacío sin
música sería una persona totalmente
diferente que viviría otra vida
totalmente diferente y eso aunque
antonio diga que en un futuro puede
cambiar todavía no es posible porque no
está la máquina del tiempo entonces esto
que yo os acabo de contar en mi
experiencia personal y por tanto es
posible es un proceso largo pero es
posible y para saber que hay ahora hay
que saber de dónde se viene entonces yo
os invito a echarle un vistazo a las
músicas pasadas hacer un viaje en el
tiempo a esas músicas pasadas a
cuidarlas a quererla animarlas a
investigar las a estudiarlas porque así
entre todos podremos sentar las bases de
una sociedad más abierta a la cultura y
en definitiva y por tanto de un mundo
mejor muchas gracias
[Música]